on n'a pas besoin de ces privilèges 5
sur son besoin de se déclarer comme son
besoin de vous
je voulais juste m'intégrer faire
partout un gros ça parce qu'on gagne pas
voir des amis puis jouer avec tout le
monde pète heureuse accès car canal fin
pour le groupe se séparait en deux comme
ça c'est paul von je voulais pas avoir à
choisir veut juste faire partie du
groupe
donc émis une période où un moment donné
toi tu as commencé à parler plus à
dénoncer plus oui mais ça m'est arrivé
donc là je me rappelle qu il ya vait
professeur que j'aime vraiment beaucoup
le testeur ne prend pas sa préférée
meyer un lieu qui était un peu plus là
je dire à comprendre qu'ils faisaient
pas tous passer de bois puis a commencé
à les supprimer pour l'insulter me le
dis devant toute la classe de français
sans voix c'est ce puis j'ai vu qu'il
n'a peut-être pas bon je vais quand même
enlevé la voie puis j'ai dit non mais tu
as épaules se fait pas
mais le professeur vraiment très content
que que gimont qui est proche des
limites c'est que ça ne faisait pas
parce qu'il veut pas qu'à timide
quelqu'un qui voit pas tout le temps que
tu franchi une limite
puis manille à un point de non retour
qui était tout à fait le garçon et fille
les pommiers puis que les c'est génial
de se faire reprendre comme site pour
toute la place enfin que j'irai que que
c'est pas mal la première fois que je me
suis assuré